I'm just intensely curious about people
and social behavior
everything that I'm doing is just my way
of satisfying that Curiosity
my work as a photographer is deeply more
than culture
excited to travel to Fort Worth to
explore all the old western Traditions
that make the city what it is
okay this is where the magic starts can
I take something that you're doing sure
absolutely
when I start shooting a project I just
like to arrive in a place and really
just follow my intuition
I don't really have a plan
that's very exciting actually
I'm most excited to photograph the
longhorn cattle drive which I've only
heard about that it's one of the most
unique traditions in Fort Worth
good morning
welcome to Fort Worth have you been
around Texas Longhorn cattle before
never
everything that I've seen has been
almost a little surreal
I've never seen this in real life
I've seen the only western movies but
what's unique about their breed is
they're all different colors different
sizes these are Miniature steel these
actually are 2022 World Champion
miniature
it's very distinguished some of the
horns are going up some are straight out
some are twisting
and they grow throughout their entire
life so they're they're just magnificent
steers I didn't realize the horns are
going to be so huge and so beautiful
they're bigger than life huge
and we'll go out the gray gate
the reason why we do this is we're
commemorating a time in history when
Longhorns were driven through Fort Worth
along What's called the Chisholm Trail
so we're preserving Western Heritage the
American Cowboy and of course the Texas
Longhorn
[Music]
joining the herd today is really just an
incredible experience to witness
[Music]
thank you my pleasure yes ma'am
I mean one of my favorite things about
travel is that it opens my eyes to new
experiences and your cultures
that was amazing it was like a dance
I really can't wait to get back to Texas
and have more Adventures here
[Music]